there has been a lot of data about how
birth control can actually like help
with hormonal regulations and although I
would have agreed with you if we lived
in a completely natural world maybe that
would be the case where it's like oh no
like it causes more imbalances and for
some women it does
um the fact of the matter is there's so
much hormones in our food there's so
many things that we're consuming on a
day-to-day basis that affect our Cycles
personally I got an IUD and it really
changed my life for the better and the
reason why I say that is because before
that my hormones were all out of whack
probably has to do with my food maybe
genetics things like that and once I was
able to get it my period reduced my
cramps reduced I was able to actually
start like living a more fulfilling life
and not just being put out of commission
one week every month